en francia la justicia se está
convirtiendo en un aliado del movimiento
climático los tribunales ordenaron este
jueves al estado que repare las
consecuencias por sus compromisos
incumplidos en materia de reducción de
las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero
histórico se trata de una jurisprudencia
histórica que abre una nueva era para la
política climática en francia ya que con
esta sentencia los dirigentes políticos
se ven obligados a respetar los
compromisos climáticos asumidos por
francia netflix y palafolls el litigio
había sido llevado ante el tribunal
administrativo de parís en 2019 por
cuatro ong bajo el lema el caso del
siglo respaldado por una petición de más
de 2.3 millones de ciudadanos
denunciaban las deficiencias del estado
en la lucha contra el calentamiento
global durante el período comprendido
entre 2015 y 2018 dos millones de
personas firmaron para demandar al
estado francés por inacción climáticas
francia tiene hasta finales de 2022 para
reparar los daños sin embargo la
sentencia deja discreción del la
elección de las medidas a tomar para
hacerlo y rechaza la petición de las ong
de una sanción económica de 78 millones
de euros por cada semestre de retraso
suscribir al donante de life is good
hope de dónde son el tribunal está hasta
el 31 de diciembre de 2022 y eso va más
allá de la campaña presidencial esto
significa que es vinculante para el
gobierno actual que tiene seis meses
para publicar decretos y hacer cosas y
también es vinculante para los
candidatos a las elecciones
presidenciales el gobierno francés tomó
nota de la decisión afirmando ser
plenamente consciente de sus
obligaciones y de la necesidad de seguir
acelerando sus esfuerzos contra la
crisis climática